Getting to know you has made me feel very protective of you,...
...especially because I have two daughters who are about your age, college-aged kids.
And it has also made me realize that you don't need protection...
...because you're absolutely ready and prepared to take on the world.
And if you have attended the Wurtele Center for Work and Life,...
...you even have a "Passport to Life after Smith,"...
...with the opportunity to learn things like job interviewing skills,...
...how to balance a budget, cook a healthy meal, and even change a tire.
So you can consider my speech today a continuation of the "Passport to Life after Smith,"...
...though in the interest of full disclosure, I can't cook and definitely cannot change a tire.
But part of life after Smith will be deciding what things do you want to put your energy into...
...and what things you don't.
It was a big revelation for me...
...when I realized that I didn't have to complete everything I thought I wanted to do,...
...like learning German or becoming a good skier or learning to cook.
Indeed, I realized that you can complete a project by dropping it.
Now, commencement speakers are traditionally expected to tell graduates...
...how to get out there and climb the ladder of success.
But I want to ask you instead to redefine success...
...because the world you are headed into desperately needs it...
...and because you are up to it.
Your education at Smith has made it unequivocally clear...
...that you are entitled to take your place in the world on equal footing...
...in every field and at the top of every field.
But what I urge you to do...
...is not just to take your place at the top of the world, but to change the world.